There's a stereotype floating around out there
that the poor are more likely to steal and
lie.
But the science reveals, that stereotype couldn't
be further from the truth.
Hey friends, Laci Green here for Dnews.
In the past few years there's been a lot of
hubbub about the wealth gap and income inequality
and the one percent.
Scientists are asking, what are the real differences
between the behavior the rich and the poor?
30 studies have been conducted so far on wealth
and behavior and the results are pretty intense
actually.
Prepare yourselves.
Across the US, no matter what your political
background or where you live, the rich are
consistently more likely to cheat, lie, steal,
and be kind of terrible to other people.
One of the studies published in the Proceedings
of the National Academy of Sciences looked
at driving behavior.
They found that those who drive luxury vehicles
were three to four times less likely to stop
for a pedestrian.
Those in higher status cars would often zoom
through the crosswalk even when they saw that
a pedestrian was standing there waiting.
While the lower status cars almost always
stopped.
Another study tested lab participants' honesty
in a dice rolling game.
The researchers told participants that if
they made the best dice rolls, they would
win a prize.
Using a hidden camera, they found that the
participants who made over $150,000 a year
were four times as likely to cheat than those
who only made $15,000 a year.
Yea the rich participants made about as much
as the poor participants do per month.
And what was the prize?
Fifty bucks.
Moral of the story here, "don't get rich or
you'll become terrible."
Or is it that you become rich because you
are already terrible?
Philosophical question yo.
Another study shed some light here.
It suggests that it's the wealth itself that
taints our minds that drives further greed
and entitlement.
In this experiment, hundreds in UC Berkeley
students were paired up to play a round of
Monopoly with each other,
with a catch.
The students were randomly assigned, based
on a dice roll, to be rich or poor.
The rich players started out with two thousand
more and they got to roll two dice.
The poor player got no pay advantage and they
could only roll with one die.
So the game was rigged for rich player to
win, no matter what happened.
But after the game, these unassuming innocent
students who merely played rich, said that
they deserved to win.
Girl you won because the dice landed in your
favor at the beginning of the game!
Let's not get ahead of ourselves.
You know what I'm saying.
So these studies aren't necessarily groundbreaking.
There were other studies that found upper-income
folks are more likely to shoplift.
A study in Psychological Science found lower
empathetic accuracy in wealthy participants
compared to the poor and uneducated.
The poor also give a higher percentage of
their money to charity than the rich do.
I don't know, it kinda makes me have all these
weird feelings about money and stuff.
I mean what does it all mean?
Let me know what you guys think down below
and I'll be sure to link some further reading
in the description if you're interested in
that kinda thing.
Hit subscribe for more Dnews every day and
I'll see you next time.